to succeed you must failed in failure in
his suffering
all the answers are in there the problem
with passion is that you and I have
bought into this massive fantasy world
where we think that passion is a person
or a place or a thing if you're in sales
make 300 cold calls a day 300 cold calls
a day wanna be happy
build a life not a business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the skills that you
weren't taught in school that will
improve your life skill number one
enduring suffering with David Goggins so
the thing about my say suffering people
cringe people that thought that the one
word whenever I post about it people
cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you had to dis go
to a place that's just every day of your
life is suffering you have to tap into
suffering every day of your life because
we have so much scarring that we have to
clean up you have to look at suffering
as almost like I look at failure to
succeed you must fail in failure and in
suffering all the answers are in there
all the answers to all the test
questions the test is your life all the
answers are in there you have to live in
suffering and pain and failure all the
time you have to learn I need to visit
it like people hate working out you're
only gonna visit working out maybe an
hour a day 23 other hours of the day
you're not in it hmm but how you become
in shape is you must visit suffering
visits working out one hour a day visit
suffering one hour a day visit your past
failures one hour a day the relationship
with it is the answers are in there they
they are in there within the suffering
go in there and I caught the lie of
autopsy the live autopsy how do you find
out someone died they crack you open
after you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive go back in your brain crack it
open while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it why you are living go in there go
into the suffering go into the pain of
your life and say why did this suck for
me so bad why am I afraid of all this
stuff why if I shut down the whole world
I guarantee I'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these
nooks of the suffering within your brain
in the scarring are all the answers to
why you are on the couch feeling sorry
for yourself they lie within the scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them and then you'll find out more
about yourself you will then grow so
don't look at this every day I suffer go
into it an hour a day learn from
yourself learn from life learn from your
failures learn from your insecurities
learn from your self-doubt don't just
say I'm afraid he's about the airplane
hmm what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why I studied my mind why became
so powerful in the mind because I
realized I was weak so instead of
running away from the mind I'd old into
us and what is making me weak oh this
makes sense I came from hell
I came from a place that beat me down to
nothing which is why I'm afraid all this
makes sense so systematically one by one
I went back and met every single person
in my mind every situation I went
one-on-one with them again in my mind
it's okay that's now revisit this and
that's how you do it that's how it works
skill number two finding your purpose
with Mel Robbins
the problem with passion is that you and
I have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay has a
needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're gonna find that one
person or you're going to find that one
thing that you're meant to do or you're
gonna find that career and honestly we
got to change the way that you think
about passion and purpose before you
will actually be able to bring it into
your life because the truth is passion
isn't in a person it isn't in a place
and it isn't in a thing it's something
inside of you and when you flip the
definition of what passion is and when
you actually understand what you're
looking for when you say I
want to discover my passion then you'll
be able to create more of it in your
life here's your new definition of
passion passion is simply energy that's
all that it is okay passion is what you
feel when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay I want you
to think about that for a minute
I want you to think about a moment in
time when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay and why don't you
in the comments tell me where are you
watching from and tell me about a moment
in time when you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were about the people
that you are with describe that moment
for me because when you start to really
investigate passion as energy this is
what you're going to discover those
moments when you are super passionate
like I'm sure my kids would write down
when they're doing community theater
with all their friends I would write
down whenever I'm doing any kind of
creative project with my team I'm
incredibly energized whenever I'm doing
group exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walkathon I'm incredibly energized by
that whenever I'm doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever I'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever I am coaching someone or giving
advice I am incredibly energized by that
and so what I want you to understand is
that if you look back on your life you
have had moments where you have felt
passion now I'm being very deliberate
and how I'm talking this morning on
coffee talk because passion is a huge
topic for so many of you and you've been
so focused on trying to figure out what
job is gonna make me passionate what job
is my passion what is my purpose on the
earth I'm gonna tell you what your
purpose on earth is right now your
purpose on earth is to figure out
how to align your life so that you feel
more energized and excited by it that's
it and it begins with you following the
energy and following your natural
enthusiasm you're not going to think
your way to passion you can't think your
way to finding something that you feel
in your heart it doesn't work that way
you got to feel your way into it it's
inside of you do you understand there's
no passion out there somewhere the
passion is in here and so what you have
to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're gonna find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you also if you want
to learn how to have more confidence
check of my 254 series they're free the
links are in description below after you
practice Marshall to develop this
natural self confidence not cockiness
but you develop this natural self
confidence everything I didn't want to
do is what got me to where I'm at today
you might want to get honest with
yourself I can study doing this be a
billionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make honey
skill number three the art of sales with
Dan Payne yeah if you're in sales make
300 cold calls a day 300 cold calls a
day 300 cold calls a day correct will it
still work no we got kids doing it was a
question we even got some lazy got kids
doing it right now just pick up the
phone yeah yeah I mean for a Dutch kid
24 years old to make twenty cold calls a
day you think it's a big deal there's
nobody's teaching sales in this country
that I'm aware of that tells you that
makes 300 cold calls a day
in fact there's nobody on the planet
that I'm aware of that tells you to make
300 phone calls a day I had a guy just
do a 50 million dollar deal he said Dan
if you just told me I was 2,000 cold
calls away from my first deal I would
have sent you a check for 20 grand
and said thank you and I want to come to
the castle skill number for the skill of
public speaking with Dan Locke
the number one fear that most people
have is public speaking now why do so
many people why are they afraid of
speaking the group's most of the time
because they worry about if they're
gonna sound stupid or how do they look
or they are afraid because they might
say something wrong all these things but
you look at great leaders almost all
great leaders they're all great public
speakers such as Steve Jobs right such
as Tony Robbins one Buffett one of the
skills that changed my life is public
speaking
when I joined Toastmasters years ago
because I wanted to improve my English
and also reduce my accent and I was
improving myself through public speaking
I developed confidence self confidence
through public speaking so ask yourself
are you afraid to speak to groups do you
know how to present your ideas to groups
can you communicate with conviction and
certainty can you interact with your
audience maybe you get sweaty palms
maybe you were like me in the beginning
like your face would would turn pale all
right your knees would be locked that's
okay it is a learnable skill but in
order to be rich public speaking is one
of the most valuable skills that you
must master and skill number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is the skill of influence and
persuading with Jordan Belfort Warren
Buffett was doing the speech of Bill
Gates about me ten years ago and he was
asked by a college student what can we
do as students to make ourselves more
valuable in the workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whatever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and conservation there he did
Dale Carnegie changed his life there you
go now that point because he took they
said I took Dale Kearney changement
without that you don't he'd be without
that course yeah he'd be the richest
money manager in Omaha Nebraska then no
one ever heard of yeah Annie met his
wife that way but the love of his life
was without the ability to influence and
persuade
yeah okay you can't put yourself out
there into the world and be known for
what you really are now got a special
bonus clip for you around the skill of
developing good habits with James clear
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question it's time
to go from just watching the video and
to taking action here we go question
number one what suffering do you need to
endure through right now number two how
can you use your purpose to bring value
to other people and number three how
will you improve your public speaking
skills this weekend one of the phrases I
use I have this in the book is that
habits are the compound interests of
self-improvement so it's like the same
way that it's very compound interest you
know cruise through finance you're the
effects of your habits multiply over
time and so often these choices that you
make they're these little 1%
improvements for you or against you each
day and they're very easy to overlook on
a daily basis right like what what
really is the difference between eating
a burger and fries or a salad chicken
for lunch
you don't take a lot moment that's
actually a crucial point that I cover in
the book which is that habits that are
immediately satisfying are more likely
to be repeated and so pretty much any
behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time right like if you eat a
doughnut right now it's tasty and sugar
good but in the long run you gain weight
and so the the immediate outcome is
favorable the long-term outcome is
unfavorable with good habits to soften
the reverse I'd like you go to the gym
right now and it takes effort you sweat
you have to work hard it's the Sun you
got your time for Netflix and chill to
go train the immediate outcomes
unfavorable but the ultimate outcome
you're in shape and you you know a year
or month or whatever right it's
favorable and so the challenge for
building good habits and breaking bad
ones is often finding a way to pull the
long term consequences of your bad
habits in the immediate moment so you
feel a little that the pain right now
and want to avoid it and the long-term
rewards of your good habits into the
immediate moment so you have a reason to
repeat it again in the future each
behavior Casa vote for the type of
person that you want to become and if
you cast enough votes for that type of
identity you start to believe that about
yourself right like if you go to church
for 20 years you believe that you're
religious you study Spanish every
Tuesday for
thirty minutes you believe that you were
studious so in that way your habits
provide evidence of your desired
identity and I think that that is
probably the ultimate reason that habits
are so importantly it's true like how
this can help you earn more money or be
more productive or lose weight and all
that stuff is great but in addition to
the external results that habits provide
they also shape your sense of self they
like are the at the engine or the Avenue
through which you learn to believe
things about yourself like sometimes
people will say stuff like fake it till
you make it but fake it till you make it
is asking yourself to believe something
without evidence for it and you can do
that for a little while you can do it
for a day or week but eventually I mean
there's a word for beliefs that don't
have evidence by those delusion right
and if you're deluding yourself then
eventually you give up on that but the
power of doing a better habit each day
or casting one little vote for that type
of person is that now you have evidence
to root your belief in so now I've done
our very last months Yeah right like
yeah I mean now you have a lot of
evidence that you're a podcaster or a
good interviewer you know like you do
this over and over again each time you
cast a vote for believing that about
yourself and you don't just you're not
delusional II believing that you're a
good interviewer it's because you've
shown up and done it hundreds of times
right and so I think that that's true
for any habit large or small that they
provide evidence of the desired identity
or the type of person that you are hmm
what are the five non-negotiable habits
for you on a daily basis oh that's a
good question so there are a few core
habits that are gonna serve everybody
and certainly serve me well so exercise
is a huge one
I don't do it daily but I exercise I
train four times a week yeah and I feel
like if I didn't exercise I don't know
that I would be an entrepreneur like I
don't know if I could handle the
psychological rollercoaster without the
physical oh yeah the release the you
probably feel that as like an athlete
too you know like I for being an athlete
for so many years I feel like I need to
push myself physically in addition to
mentally it isn't just mental it doesn't
do it for me I don't have a physical
outlet so exercise exercise is one the
other the ultimate meta habit is reading
because if you build a habit of reading
you can solve pretty much any other
problem you know you won't learn how to
be a better podcaster you can read about
that you want to write how to meditate
you can read about that you want
now to make more money you can read
about that and so what you need is to
develop a habit of reading and then
whatever problem you're facing at the
time you can you have a method for
solving them
if you want to learn the five Universal
skills to make you rich go check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
humungous GPA and other [ __ ] which you
need is the one thing I talked on my
book if I could go back and you could
only give me one skill